we recently witnessed that weird
spectacle of Ali Velshi at MSNBC reading
scripture to attack the administration's
immigration policy that followed
Attorney General Jeff Sessions quoting
the Bible to justify that policy so all
of this has sparked a really big debates
really interesting among Christian
leaders over immigration so let's
discuss that now with a pair of very
distinguished religious leaders I'm
delighted the vote with us dr. Daryl
Scott of the president's faith advisory
council and dr. Kent Engel president of
Southeastern University great to see you
both all right dr. Engel let's start
with you you're actually I think a
supporter of the president's but you
disagree with this policy that initially
at least separated families child and
one area parents more in a formal
immigration detention why sure well I
appreciate president Trump's leadership
and he's he's trying to do the right
thing
he wants to uphold the laws of the land
there's no doubt about that
I think the issue there was to not only
provide protection which is what he
wants to do as it relates to borders but
I think also the issue has to you have
to look at compassion how do you bring
the human element into this situation so
that you can provide human dignity and
respect and care and compassion and and
provide an element that gives both and I
think that's the thing that a lot of
Americans are hoping that our president
will step up in a way along with the
Congress the House the Senate our
leaders will do the right thing and
provide that protective and
compassionate pieces to this legislation
pastor Scott this is Bishop Michael
Curry who was just slamming jeff
sessions for invoking the bible let's
watch for a christian to quote romans 13
over jesus of nazareth as a jesus of
nazareth doesn't exist that that it
seems to me is highly problematic and
it's just flat-out wrong it's unbiblical
it's unchristian and it's not American
pastor well your reaction to that and I
have
something to say about welcoming the
stranger go ahead well this and it's not
unreasonable to refer to scriptures
especially if you're a Bible believer
it's not unusual to refer to scriptures
as a basis to validate any actions that
you engage in once again if you're a
Bible believer we oftentimes use
scripture to confirm a validate actions
or activity that we engage in I don't
see anything wrong with Jeff Sessions
utilizing that scripture because that
scripture simply says to obey there's
civil authorities notice something Jesus
nor the Apostle Paul never endorsed
sedition or rebellion or violent
uprising against Rome and then using
that scripture he was saying that in
order to advance our cause violence is
not - the way obey the laws of the land
so they won't have a reason to accuse us
for any wrongdoing obey the laws of the
land and put other matters into the
hands of God and he'll work it out
pastor angle the the Bible calls us
calls on us to welcome the stranger and
and it's very powerful welcomed into
your table if someone you know invite a
stranger to your home for meals and so
forth but the Catholic Bishops seem to
take that to mean open borders I mean
they get a really big wall around the
Vatican it's a beautiful wall really
nice wall but that means anyone who
steps foot over the border has to be
processed into the country and released
how is that welcoming the stranger
according to biblical text that is not
meaning that does not mean to be devoid
of all laws of the land does it
absolutely and and and I go back to that
passage the Attorney General referred to
in Romans 13 talking about you know obey
the laws of the land when you talk about
the context of God's law God's law as
always for protection it's always for
peace it's always for harmony and so
that's why when you look at the issues
that we are facing with immigration
reform all the issues challenges that we
have seen over the last couple of weeks
you have to have a come together
approach that covers all the issues of
well you have to look at the issue of
collaborating on providing security at
the wall you have to look at issues of
compassion as it
what I mean we all do what we can to
donate to organizations that help people
on the ground in their home countries
I mean so many Christian organizations
faith-based groups in Guatemala Central
America South America Africa around the
world that's where we as individuals can
make a difference through our faith
through our churches and our
organizations correct it doesn't mean
that we have to completely smash our own
rule of law and say okay you have a
really sad life
I understand it's horrible so we have to
allow you to come into the country no
matter how you come in but I want to
play something for you and I want to I
want to get Pastor Scott on this this is
a very liberal priest known as father
James Martin he's not a big fan of Trump
to put it lightly this is what he said
no one wants to be a refugee no one
wants to be a migrant but they do it out
of great love for their families they
have a lot of guts to do it and I think
it's up to us to welcome them I think
the problem with them a lot of these
Christians who are saying that they're
reading the Bible is a I don't know what
Bible they're reading because the Bible
I read has Jesus always reaching out to
those who are on the margins including
and most especially migrants and
refugees Americans feel like they're on
the margins like two blocks from where
we're broadcasting from there are a lot
of homeless on the streets literally two
blocks from where we are there's a
difference between migrants refugees or
illegal immigrants these are the parents
of these children know that they are
committing a crime
well they endeavored to sneak into this
country this country has a
zero-tolerance policy they know that our
president is hardline in regards to that
but they tried to sneak in any way now
anyone an American citizen regardless of
your race creed or color if you are
engaged in the commission of a crime and
you are caught in the commission of this
crime and you are apprehended and you
have a child in your custody that child
is going to be removed from your custody
and placed in the child services until
either somebody comes and gets them or
they're remanded over to or whatever and
so I don't understand why we're taking
any culpability for this crime
that has been committed away from the
parents and making it as if with just
just grabbing kids and putting them in a
concentration camp because that is not
the case at all there's a crime being
committed the children are in the
customers fall and it's Donald because
you told yourself I'm gonna sneak into
America I'm gonna sneak into America
despite the law and I'm taking my time
I wouldn't even put my children at risk
like that I have grandchildren I
wouldn't even try to do that if I knew
it was a dangerous a dangerous journey
that's for sure up through Mexico
phenomenal segment thank you both